darrel mousse Johnston fox sports
analyst three times Super Bowl champ
with the Cowboys he called the Niners
Redskins game yesterday with Chris Myers
and moose joins us now what's the most
pain you ever been in as a football
player back pain back pain and well the
neck to because it's a it's a it's a
different kind of pain
it's that nerve pain that nothing really
seems to mitigate so yeah that and then
you fall asleep in the afternoon because
you've been fighting foods like the pain
all day so I remember when Emmet Emmet
played with that separated shoulder
right yes yeah bad man full for running
back yeah exactly
exactly because of the movement it's
funny the shoulder is like a joint that
nobody really consider is important on
yet and that in the world of football I
guess because you know if you heard an
ankle or a knee or elbows everybody's
always concerned but with the shoulder
it's just like well we'll we'll just
shoot up you can go play not any I mean
you can't brush your teeth you can't
comb your hair you find out on what you
actually use your shoulder once you
heard it so yeah that was uh that was
that was a tough one for now and that
lingers for a while how much hiding of
injuries goes on or at least went on
when you played well to the point during
my career was when they got really
strict with kind of classification of
the injury you know whether you know
doubtful out you know the the categories
that they have in place probable you
know they wanted a little bit more
[Music]
strictness with the classification
because some guys at the end of the week
when all of a sudden go for probable
doubt and they felt like they were kind
of hiding something that was going on
early in a week and then I know we
actually had a situation but it was a
Friday injury Troy actually hurt his his
thumb on on Friday getting ready for a
San Francisco game and so he was on the
injury report Friday probably not as out
but it was a pretty substantial injury
mean that was one of the times that the
league came to us and said okay we need
to we just need to know you know who's
injured you know going into the weekend
and that's and then
Jimmy I think Jimmy that would put like
anybody who had anything on the injury
list and said like what did you take
away from the Cowboys last night that
performance against the Eagles well
that's who they can be and that's been
kind of the frustrating work for them
this year they've been very inconsistent
very up-and-down so when when they're
functioning and firing on all cylinders
you know that's the potential that that
team has you know the takeaway thing is
obviously a huge part at the early part
of that game it's something that they've
struggled with for the past couple of
years and they work on it they preach it
they teach it but they haven't been able
to transfer it from the practice field
to the game field but they did last
night and that's a huge part for them so
you know that's that's got to be the
frustrating part not only for the fans
but further for the players also knowing
you know what the potential is and the
fact that they got on that three-game
losing streak
if Jason Garrett's a hot commodity is
Jerry Jones says then why doesn't he
just sign him to a new deal great
question great question I think it'll
get done I'm sure that there's probably
a benchmark that the organization has
out there that they'd like to see the
team achieve and then they'll kind of
work through that decision but but do
you think that is most how far do they
have to go I think the NFC title game
for Jason and keep his job but look I've
been wrong the past couple years with
what I thought was going to be Jerry
Jones tolerance here I'm always the guy
that at the end of a season you really
have to look back and see if you didn't
reach the goals that you wanted to reach
what were the reasons why because a lot
of times there's there's actual reasons
why but if you have you're free and
clear if you don't have a major injury
if there wasn't uh you know some type of
adversity during the course of this
season that kind of gave you a big bump
in the road then then you've got to
evaluate you know you know very very
hard but but I would agree with you if
we're if we're saying that we have to
get better every season then the
benchmark for the Dallas Cowboys would
be at least an appearance in the NFC
Championship game which would show
growth from previous seasons and and
that's that's the big challenge right
now with Jason is Jason has a
beyond the divisional round so that
would be a huge step for for Jason and
for for the team so if the organization
is taking the position that we have to
see improvement from the previous
seasons under this staff in Jason
Garrett specifically then an appearance
in the NFC Championship game would be
that benchmark but what what happens
down the rest of the season you know is
there something that happens later this
year that you look back on and say well
yeah we were supposed to go to the
championship game but because of this
you know maybe that was an expectation
that was too high
he's moose Johnston funk sports analyst
three-time Super Bowl champ with the
Cowboys he called the Niners and the
Redskins yesterday Niners for real where
would you rank them with the pecking
order of NFC teams right now I think the
best thing that they've done is they've
gotten to six and OH with their fourth
and fifth offensive tackle without Kyle
use check who is a type of player that
allows the running game and play action
game to expand in San Francisco's
offense and without one of their
starting corners so I think that that
shows that they have depth that the
staff is smart in their game planning to
make sure that those injuries don't
become an impact on the game so the big
thing about San Francisco as good as
they're playing right now how good are
they going to look in four weeks from
now five weeks from now when Joe Staley
is back McGlinchey is back usually jack
is back witherspoon is back because then
that offense you know the defense is
carrying that team right now
the offense is doing enough but my big
thing is what does this team look like
when everybody's back and healthy so I
think they are legitimate but I think
the West is also very tough you know
when you've got Seattle the Rams and in
Arizona Arizona starting to figure it
out you know with all the changes that
happened in the offseason you know that
takes a little bit of time to get the
chemistry back with the group and it
looks like it looks like Arizona's
figuring some stuff out so you know they
they could be a team that sneaks up and
and gives you know some issues to one of
those top teams in the West it feels
like there's at least one game
year with the Redskins at home where
they remind us of just how bad their
football field is or is that just me I
mean to me it to look I know that it
wasn't ideal conditions but it almost
feels like it's a Division three
football program with that field you
know Dan that's a great point and you
know that they took the tarp off and
within 20 minutes 25 minutes of the tarp
being taken off that field there was
already puddles for me the grass is not
thick you can actually see some bare
spots from our boot from the broadcast
we look down to the field you could see
about six areas on the field that we're
puddling you know 40 45 minutes prior to
kick my big thing is how close some of
the seats are at the end of the end
zones I'm amazed that we haven't had a
severe injury at FedEx Field you know
with a guy at the back of the end zone
trying to make a catch and getting
pushed because to me there's just not
enough space there yeah you know for
safety and then I agree I agree I I
think that the Redskins is one of the
things they really seriously need to
consider is either upgrading that one or
moving to something different or or
finding a new groundskeeper you know at
least because you know it it gets
dangerous you know in situations when
you have the weather that we had and you
have a field that can't absorb that
water and it can't get rid of it I mean
you get to other fields and and you see
how it holds the bad weather whether
it's rain snow you know the majority of
the fields in the NFL function well but
that one that one was not that was not
NFL caliber yesterday and and they're
lucky that somebody didn't get hurt
maybe they change the ownership there I
don't think so either but you know that
might solve a lot of things there
because it feels like you know the front
office doesn't take any blame for this
it's everybody else takes the blame for
what the Redskins have done would you
just start tanking if you're wanting are
they stanking no guys don't do that it
was so frustrating when this is that
about the Miami Dolphins you can't you
can't get 53 men to tank you work too
hard but I can put an inferior motivated
didn't play for moose I can
I can this called front-office tanking
it's like Derek Jeter and the Marlins
they put an inferior product on the
field the guys on the field are gonna
play hard but it feels like Miami has
put an inferior product on the field
just like the Miami Marlins did well
you're going through a massive
restructuring with Brian Flores he's
gonna put his own spin on it he's
grabbing assets as quickly as he can you
know he's he's got a window that he
thinks he needs to perform in so he's
doing it that way we're gonna we're
gonna over Paul this whole thing it
happened when Jimmy came there was a lot
of guys in and out of our locker room on
and off our roster you know that first
year first year and a half with Jimmy so
everybody understands the transition
when we have a new head coach but to say
that Washington is tanking there's some
talented football players on that team a
Ryan Kerrigan is not going to tank
Jonathan Alan's not going to tank you
know there's too much there's too much
pride in that and and and your you know
coaches watch and that's one of the
things that you try to tell the fans
when they when they bring up this topic
is there's free agency in this league
and if you're not happy here there's
gonna be an opportunity for you to go
somewhere else but if you put on your
your resume that you're a guy who
doesn't play hard the entire game
because something happened during the
course of that season they're going to
remember that they're going to know that
and they're not going to bring you under
there to you if they have you know the
suspicion that you're a guy that hey
when things go wrong this is a guy that
doesn't play hard you know you're not
going to get the opportunities to stay
along to stay long in this league so
it's frustrating for me when I hear
scenarios like that sometimes it's
business generate sometimes it's just
what's going on that season but but I
it's hard for me to accept that that
players would be tanking on the field
moose great to talk to you please give
our best to Chris Myers and thanks for
joining us safe travels absolutely good
luck with those ibuprofen thanks bud
yeah I need something a little stronger
Darryl moose Johnston Fox Sports analyst
and three-time Super Bowl champ with the
Cowboys for more Dan Patrick show tune
in to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan patch
show app
[Music]